and you know this this last question
it's it's not really a question well it
look I get a lot of awesome emails and I
get emails from people that have
completely turned their lives around
they've they've lost weight if they need
to lose weight or they've gained weight
because they needed to gain weight or
they've gotten promoted or they've
become a better parent or they've become
a better spouse or they become a better
kid yeah and I get emails from people
that have quit their addictions or
they've or they've overcome their fear
and say what I get letters and packages
and notes about all this kind of stuff
then it's awesome I get I get people
send me books for the podcast and
pictures and drawings and and and
military memorabilia or unit patches and
coins from the police departments and
fire departments and and military units
it's just it's awesome and and um I'm so
thankful for all that feedback and it it
drives me that feedback that I get
drives me to work hard and keep pushing
to do this to the best of my ability and
try and get better at it but you know I
hear from people that have used the
podcast and the discipline and the the
mindset of looking at things that are
problematic as being good I hear from
people that have used those things to
overcome
you know dark patches yeah in their
lives you know whether it's depression
or anxiety or even like full-fledged
despair and again when you hear from
people that are turned that corner
that's just incredibly rewarding to know
that there's you know there's people out
there that are really changing for the
better and turning their lives from
negative to positive it's unbelievably
rewarding but I also get some other
emails and I get some other messages
from people that haven't been able to
dig out of that hole to overcome that
that despair I hear from people
sometimes that feel there's nowhere
nowhere else to go there's no way out
and they don't have any more options and
they are considering taking the only way
out that they can see and that is they
want to take their own life and
to anybody out there that's in that
place you know I don't really know what
exactly to tell you but I can kind of
tell you what I think I think no I think
no I think don't save that last bullet
for yourself don't save it for yourself
you lock and load that last bullet and
you shoot it at your enemy and when
you're out of bullets
get out your knife and attack with that
and if you lose your knife and you grab
your enemy by the throat and you keep
fighting and you keep fighting and you
keep fighting and you keep fighting no
matter what and you never quit never
never quit
and if you can you'll like your life
isn't a place where you can't get any
lower and you don't think you can find
any way out good because that means the
ultimate challenge is ahead of you it
means you can only go up and it also
means that things are gonna be tough
things are gonna be tougher than
anything you can imagine
but that storm that you're in from from
your perspective it seems like that
storm is enveloping the whole world but
I'm telling you it is not the storm that
you're in it is hard to see out of that
storm it's hard to see past it it seems
like the storm it seems like the storm
is everything but the storm is not
everything and it won't last forever you
can get out of the storm and you will
get out of the storm and when you get
out you're gonna see the Sun again
but right now you're being tried you're
being forged you're being tested by fire
and by pain that's the test don't fail
the test don't fail the test don't give
in don't quit don't ever quit fight on
fight through the storm
fight through the pain and come out the
other side stronger and tougher and
better a fighter a survivor a winner
victorious and free from that storm free
from the darkness free